à la demande générale même si on existe
seulement depuis deux mois
la natif remet ses prix annuels c'est
surtout de l'occasion en fait de paris
contenu qu'on veut pas entendre parler
dans les dix premiers mois de l'année où
ce n'était pas en ondes
mais voilà qu'à la la retenue de l'année
sans contredit la recrue de l'année
c'est alfonso davis
non pas parce qu'il est la quête
canadien de l'année ou encore l'un des
onze meilleurs joueurs au monde selon
fifpro mais bel et bien parce que c'est
un génie des réseaux sociaux et son
meilleur coup sur deux secteurs est
certainement arrivé au début de l'année
quand il a interprété tous les
personnages du célèbre de brooklyn my
mind over one fm ouais il réussit à lui
seul à offrir plus de diversité que
l'adaptation québécoise
le retour de l'année 2020 c'est l'année
où est ce que les moins de 30 ans ont
découvert que michael jordan était autre
chose qu'une ombre chinoise sur des
souris trop cher où le personnage
principal de ce podium cm 30 ans
connaissent au special forces a changé
le monde la série de last dance nous
aurait également donné un nouveau même
de michael jordan
exit la face pleureuses bienvenus la
phase rieuse de michael jordan
certainement le même sportif de l'année
juste devant les caps droit de timbre et
des partisans de l'année
l'année a été difficile pour les
amateurs de sport qui ont été privés
pendant la majorité de l'année
d'assister à leur événement favori
néanmoins certains ont réussi à se
glisser entre les mailles comme barack
obama dans la bulle d'orlando les
personnages sont à bender ou encore des
toutous en corée peu importe quand même
celles qui méritent le titre de partisan
de l'année
c'est ashley bharti la numéro un
mondiale championne en titre à
roland-garros qui a décidé de ne pas se
présenter au tournoi parisien
à la place elle a décidé de se la couler
douce lors d'un match de football
australien bière à la main parce que là
bas ils ont réussi leur confinement
on est tous sur le plus jeune ou d'âge
santé à chaud
c'est un conglomérat mondiale de bière
vous pouvez commandité la note le moment
jaune ou de l'année depuis le mois de
mars les journalistes sportifs ont dû
redoubler d'ardeur et de créativité pour
trouver les histoires à raconter à
distance et comme tout le monde
l'apprentissage des vidéoconférences de
s'est pas fait sans douleur surtout pour
marc bergevin dans une conférence de
presse mémorable au cours de laquelle il
avait un peu l'air d'être dans un second
temps les équipes cette année
[Musique]
merci marc pour ta générosité
on n'a rien compris petit matou
catégorie sport de l'année
la catégorie sport de l'année oui ce que
je dis ce sport de l'année le water polo
tout ça c'est toujours l'espoir de
l'année à chaque année lacrampe
cerf-volant
pour notre bien les prix on s'en remet à
vous avec ses trois nommés pour la
crampe au cerveau de l'année rudy gobert
patient zéro de la corée dans la nba qui
renaît en touchant tous les micros lors
d'une conférence de presse deux jours
avant d'être déclaré positif
julian alaphilippe qui célèbre un peu
trop tôt avant de passer la ligne de
liège bastogne liège et qui se fait
battre par primer glitch novak djokovic
qui n'avait pas perdu un seul match en
2020 jusqu'à ce qu'il envoie une balle à
la gorge d'une juge de ligne aux
internationaux des états unis
cette qualification le côté près de 3
millions $ parce que dans la forme qu'il
était n'était assurément pas très degrés
le tournoi voilà tabou de moitié dans
les commentaires dites nous c'était quoi
le pire des trois mais c'est tout le
monde c'était une belle fin d'année pour
moi du moins professionnellement on se
rabat en 2021
[Musique]